طيب الاشتغال على على هذه المناخات اللي
مختصه باللغه بالحروف بشكلها وبصوتياتها
بظلك هو
يوسع الافق امامك كتشكيلي او انه يؤثرك في
هذا المناخ يعني انت بتصير ما قادر تتفلت
وتذهب الى لوحه خارج اطار اللغه يعني تحضر
برنامج ما يتخفى لغه اللغه ما يتخفى لغه
اللغه وداعوا المعنى
اللي يصير كيف اللغه تعطيك تعطيك صوره
وتعطيك اتجاه لكن لا تحدد لك ماهيه الصوره
الذهن هو اللي يفتحها فتفتح الافق يعني
مثلا انا لو عملت مشهد امامي واصور وكرسام
وانا رسام امانه حتى لكن عندما ارسم فهي
الصوره محدده امامي المثير لكن اللغه
تعطيني الطريق
والشعر بالذات بتعطيني الطريق لكن تعطيني
الغموض بنفس الاتجاه اتجه بهذا الشيء يعني
لما نقول شجره
غابه محترقه وكذا
يذهب الذهن الى
تداعيات كبيره فاذا اعطاني الصوره لكن لم
يحددها وهذا الامتياز بالنسبه الي لماذا
مثير عندي اللغه اوسع من الصوره